To find the balance after two years, we need to first start out with the amount
of money that's in the account at the beginning of the second year. We know
that's the amount that the account has at the end of the first year. 10,000
times 1 plus 0.03. Now, in fact, that's the same value that belongs in these
other two green boxes. The reason it goes here is because this is the quantity
that we're going to use to calculate the new amount of interest that needs to
be added. Now if we look at this entire expression, we can see that what can be
factored out, is what's already in the green boxes, 10,000 times 1 plus 0.03.
If we factor that out of each term, then what we would end up with for the
first term here would just be 1, and for the second term it would be 0.03, as
we see in the parentheses here. Now looking right here, what we see is repeated
multiplication of 1 plus 0.03. Using exponent notation, that gives us 10,000
times the quantity 1 plus point oh 3 squared.